invited 35 people from all
the commanders of the detachments and the
company’s management included
this meeting in the Kremlin,
it lasted almost three hours
reworking the president gave an assessment of the
company’s actions at the front during his own and also
gave his assessment of the events On June 24, Putin
listened to the explanation of the commanders and
offered further options
for employment and further combat
use, the commanders themselves outlined their
version of what happened
emphasized that they are staunch
supporters and soldiers of the head of
state and the supreme
commander in chief and also said that they
are ready to continue to fight
we will not let this happen again we will protect both
our people and our statehood from
any threats,
including
internal betrayal,
and what we faced is
betrayal,
exorbitant ambitions and personal interests
led to treason to treason to our country
and our people and to the cause for which
God and our other units and
divisions fought and died
fighters and commanders of the group
[music]